Okay, we have a young guy running his
mouth off. We'll see if he can defend
his prophet.
Uh his name is Ziyad, Z I Y A A D
Dhorat, D H O R A T.
And he's probably what, 15 years old?
How old are you? Are you older than
Aisha?
No, I mean honestly, how old are you?
How old are you?
Yeah, yeah, 17. 17, okay, sorry. He said
he's twice her age, all right. Uh he
began by saying you can't be as bad as
the Old Testament. Go to Surat
Al-Ma'idah, chapter 5 for me. Yeah, I I
did, okay, cool. Okay, can you listen
more than just go to chapter 5, read for
me?
>> it. What verse number? So you're cutting
me off again. Dude, be patient, let me
finish a sentence.
Go to chapter 5, read verses 43 all the
way to 45 slowly.
Yeah, so that people can hear you. They
want to hear you.
How can they seek judgment from you when
they have with them the Torah which
Slowly, slowly.
Slowly, my friend. Don't read it for
you, read it for the audience that
you're trying to do da'wah to. You're
trying to do da'wah to show them Islamic
truth.
Yeah, yeah, inshallah, by the grace of
Jesus, Muhammad's God and judge. So read
it slowly out loud so they can hear it.
Go ahead.
How can they seek judgment from you when
they have with them the Torah which
contains Allah's order and thereafter
they turned away. These people do not
believe.
All the way to 45.
We have certainly revealed the Torah in
which there's guidance and light. The
Anbiya who were obedient to Allah judged
the Jews with it. And the people of
Allah and the scholars because they were
instructed
to preserve Allah's book and they were
witnesses to it. So do not fear the
people but fear me and do not sell my
verses for a small gain. Whoever does
not
uh whoever does not judge by what Allah
has revealed, then they are surely the
kafirun. That is believers, yes. Do you
read Arabic, by the way?
Uh yeah, yeah, I read it. Good, good,
okay. Well, keep reading to 45. You
didn't You keep stopping, keep on.
Uh okay. We commanded them in it
a life for a life for a life and an eye
for an eye and a nose for a nose and an
ear for an ear, a tooth for a tooth and
a qisas for wounds.
Whoever acts charitably, it will be
expiation for him. Whoever does not
judge by what Allah has revealed, they
are surely the oppressors.
Okay. Now, I just sent you a link in
your comment section. Click on that
link.
All right.
I'm on it. Read it.
A group of Jews came and A group of Jews
came and invited the messenger of Allah
to
So he came in this They said Read it
louder and slowly. You're reading to
Read it People hear it louder and
slowly. Go ahead.
So she visited them in their school.
They said, "Abu Al-Qasim, one of our men
has committed fornication with a woman.
So pronounce judgment upon them."
They placed a cushion for the messenger
of Allah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam who
sat on it and said, "Bring the Torah."
It was then brought. He then withdrew
the cushion from beneath him and placed
the Torah on it saying, "I believe in
thee and in him who revealed thee." He
then said, "Bring me one who is learned
among you." Then a young man was
brought. The transmitters then mentioned
the rest of the vision of stoning
similar to the one
transmitted by Malik from
Okay, what's the grading of this
Was it sahih? Is it graded? Hasan and
Hasan, right? Okay. So in chapter 5
verse 43, it says, "Why do they come to
you saying they have the Torah?" And
that was the Torah that the Anbiya
judged by.
And then Muhammad took the copy of the
Torah they had and he put it on the
cushion and said, "I believe in you and
the one who revealed [clears throat]
you." What Torah did they have at the
time of your prophet?
The Torah
At the time of your prophet, listen to
my question so you don't It's in the
Quran.
Let me repeat it again. What Torah did
they have at the time of your prophet
that they gave to him? What was that
Torah? All right, so you want me to say
the Old Testament, right?
I didn't ask you to ask me. What Torah
did they have at the time of Muhammad?
Generally speaking, with verses like
this, the Torah is mentioned as part of
the Quran. Okay, you didn't answer my
question. This is now the fourth time.
What I'm looking into it. I'm looking at
Listen, what Torah Listen more than you
speak. I know you're young, little older
than Aisha, but still too young. Listen
so you understand how to answer.
What Torah did they have at the time of
your prophet that they gave to your
prophet that he put on a cushion and he
said, "I believe in you and the one who
revealed you."
The Old Testament. Say it again, louder.
The Old Testament, yeah.
>> You mean the Old Testament that you
marked in the comment section? No, no,
no, no. Yes, you did.
No, the Old Testament we have now has
been changed.
>> Okay. Now, the Old Testament that the
time of the Jews, was it the same that
we have today?
No. Give me the proof. Give me Mention
the man you Hold on, listen to my
question so you know how to refute me.
Point to a manuscript
at the time of your prophet of the Old
Testament that's different from we have
today.
Uh yeah, let me just quickly look it up
and then I can
>> Yeah, oh, you got to go to Sheikh
Google. Okay.
Sheikh Google. No, I love to ask
somebody who's like of knowledge. I'm
not I'm 17.
>> then why did you agree to come on my
channel to discuss with me? Now your
excuse is you have to ask someone with
knowledge. Did I You're the one who
contacted me. Hold on, for the record,
you contacted me on email. You're acting
tough in email. Why then did you accept
the chance? Why didn't you call me your
scholar?
Wait, no, on email we were talking about
separate point. No, you were telling me
that my argument What was my argument
again? What did you say in the email cuz
I got it. What did you say? Here's the
Here's the email was about the one we
were talking
>> Okay, what was the What did you call my
argument though? Say it. I was about to
tell Say it. Is that a stupid or dumb? I
don't know what to tell you yet. What
was it? You're speaking too fast.
>> I just stupid or dumb, I'm not sure
Okay, all right. So when you act bad and
you act tough, I'm going to put you in
your place. You see my point? But now,
since we're talking about the Torah,
wait, hold on. Go to chapter 5 verse 46.
Yeah, yeah, I see it.
Yeah, I got it. Read it for me slowly
and out loud so they can hear.
In their footsteps, we sent Isa, the son
of Maryam, confirming the Torah that was
before him. We gave him the Injil in
which there's guidance and light,
confirming the Torah before him. It was
also a guidance and advice for those who
adopted taqwa.
And read 47.
Uh the people of the Injil should judge
in accordance with what Allah has
revealed in it.
Whoever does not judge by what Allah has
revealed, then they are surely the
sinners.
Okay, now, in 46 when it says Jesus
confirmed the Torah before him, give me
the Arabic phrasing for the word before
him. What is it?
Bayna yadayhi.
Musaddiqan
lima bayna yadayhi, right?
All right, yeah, that's musaddiqan.
Literally translate that. What does that
literally mean?
Yeah, truth truthfulness from what came
before Not musaddiqan. The phrase bayna
yadayhi, what does that literally mean?
What came before him. No. Yadayhi does
not mean before him.
Bayna, between
and yadayhi means what?
Not sure. I'm not I'm not sure.
>> Okay. Well, because you said you read
Arabic, but anyway, that's okay. It
means between his hands.
Yadayhi, yad, between his hands. So he
confirmed the Torah between his hands,
meaning that which he had access to.
Something between your hands, that means
something that you have access to, that
you can touch, that's tangible. I want
you to remember that. Keep that in mind.
Just keep that in mind.
And then it says
Allah gave him the Gospel, the Injil,
and what did the Injil do in verse 46?
You read it. Added to light.
And we And we gave him the Gospel
confirming musaddiqan lima bayna yadayhi
min al-Tawrat, right?
Yes. Okay, so not only Jesus, but the
Gospel of Jesus confirms the Torah
between Jesus' hands.
So now I'm going to ask you the
question. What was the Torah that Jesus
had between his hands?
The Old Testament. Okay, so and we have
the Dead Sea Scrolls, copies of the
books of the Old Testament written about
200 to 100 years before Jesus that was
discovered 1947,
identical to what I'm reading today. The
only Old Testament that Jesus confirmed
based on evidence, not opinion, is what
I'm reading today. And you just attacked
that Old Testament. So are you saying
Allah misguided Jesus to confirm my Old
Testament?
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, the Old
Testament you have now is corrupted.
You're not listening. You see, young
man? You didn't listen again. Yeah,
because you're conflating the two. No,
I'm not. I just gave you historical,
archaeological proof. What
Torah did he read? You said, we got you
on record, Ziyad. You said Old [snorts]
Testament, your own mouth. And I just
told you 1947, we found copies of the
Old Testament written 200 100 years
before Jesus, written in Hebrew, proving
the only Old Testament he confirmed
would be what I have because those
copies are identical to what I have. So
now prove to me he confirmed some other
Old Testament. Give me your proof.
>> All right, so could I Okay, could I see
your proof because I can't
>> I just told you, Dead Sea Scrolls. Go to
Sheikh Google. But yes, could you show
me then? Yes, go to Google, put in Dead
Sea Scrolls Old Testament. I'm going to
give you the English translation. Hold
on, hold on, hold on.
I know you want to do the tafsir, so
hold on. Let me show it to you. Let me
get you it. I got it in the translation
in English.
>> Okay. We We have a translation of those
copies of the Old Testament between
Jesus' hands in English. Here you go. Do
you see it? Uh-huh, here you go.
Oh, yes. Okay.
>> Okay. Well, do you read it? What does it
say?
Yes, I can see it. Dead Sea Scrolls.
Okay. So, Bible. What does it say? Read
the full title.
The oldest known Bible translated for
the first time in German. Okay. And if I
open it, I'm going to show you. What
does it say? What book is it? Uh-huh.
Read it here.
Yes, yes, yes. Genesis, right?
Yes.
>> Okay. So, if your Quran is right,
Jesus confirmed between his hands the
Torah. And now we have archaeological
proof.
And it's now translated English. The
Torah he read is what I have today. Now,
give me your proof that he was reading a
different Torah from what I have today.
Yes, sure. Can I come back tomorrow with
the proof?
Yes.
>> young man, why do you email me and act
tough?
I emailed you about a specific point.
>> Okay, well,
my point is even that point we're going
to get to. Why do you Why can't you come
humbly
and gently and say, "Look, I have some
questions and objections. Can we have a
discussion where we'll talk and instead
of coming tough and acting tough?" So,
then you cause me to react as if you're
one of these Muslim punks. Why would you
do that?
What do you mean Muslim punks? You You
have punks, people have attitude who
think they're tough and they want to
come and run their mouth. But, I'm going
to put that aside. I'm going to ignore
the fact. I'm going to forget your
email. Now, I want to That's probably
because But,
probably
>> That's probably because like you swear
about their prophet and their religion
and you
>> Okay, hold on. Well, let's put it in
perspective. You mean those Muslims who
come and mock my God, insult my Jesus,
attack my Bible. Let's forget they do
that. Let's focus on me who then gives
them a taste of their own medicine. Go
to chapter 6, verse 108 of the Quran.
Read what your Quran says.
>> Chapter 1? Chapter 6, verse 108.
Read it for me.
Do not insult those whom they worship.
Yeah, I Yeah, I know this. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. No, you know this, but the people
that I attack don't know this because
the people that come on my channel and
my comment section, they do attack the
God I believe in and the Jesus I believe
in and the Bible I believe in and then
they slander us.
And so, I do what the Quran says the
unbelievers would do. Didn't the Quran
just say,
"If you attack their gods, then they
will attack Allah?"
Yeah, that doesn't justify you doing it
though.
>> No, it actually does because in my
Bible, I can put a fool in his place and
humiliate him for being a blasphemous
dog. So, my Bible says I can do that.
So, what I'm telling you,
your Quran even warned you, "Don't do
that so they don't insult Allah." So,
why do your Muslims attack my God,
attack my Jesus, attack my Bible?
I I'm telling you why they do it. I'm
not saying that's a good reason for them
to do it. I'm just telling you why they
do it. No, they have no They have no
basis to do it because 6108 says you
have no excuse. You're saying I agree.
They're wrong for doing it, but you're
wrong for
>> So, now let's put them aside. We're
going to focus you and me.
No, why are you pivoting now? No, let's
go back
>> pivoting cuz I just put you in your
place. You lied again and slandered by
saying I attacked them. No, they attack
me and I give them a taste of their
medicine.